[Music]
on this Thursday night a warning from
the president of the Canadian Medical
Association about a second wave why he
says Canada's health care system can't
handle it
were gambling by reopening frustration
over the slow pace of kovat 19 testing
believe me it's frustrating
are we forging ahead with reopening
before having enough testing and contact
tracing in place pools arenas and golf
courses near you could disappear we're a
municipality we can't run a deficit the
municipalities who say they can't keep
paying the bills and a small city's big
outbreak he filled the Buddy peens
a sore throat and in fever a coded 19
quickly tore through Brooks Alberta
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
as summer approaches and the economy
begins to open up there are warnings
tonight not to become complacent about
public health restrictions health
experts say there has never been a
pandemic in recorded history that did
not include a second wave sometimes
worse than the first and just because
we're coming to the end of a first wave
doesn't mean we can let our guard down
on things like physical distancing and
hand-washing you know I might sound like
a broken record but right now is the
time not the time to forget those core
public health measures like the physical
distance washing your hands this virus
can accelerate really quickly and so
we've seen it accelerating really fast
in that first wave so we have to be
really cautious because it might not
take much for another chain of
transmission and an escalation to occur
the president of the Canadian Medical
Association says Canada is not ready for
a second wave of CO vid 19 dr. sandy
Buckman told a Senate committee
yesterday Canada is taking a gamble by
reopening in my opinion we're not fully
prepared for a second wave you know if
we don't have adequate diagnostic
testing so original testing disease
testing for people who have the disease
and we aren't doing insufficient contact
tracing when we do adequate testing of
cases as well as the contact tracing we
can better prepare to see if the
healthcare system would be overwhelmed
we would get a much better picture of
what we should do in addition we haven't
undertakes serologic testing we have
that actually assesses the immunity
within the population we have
insufficient information as to what's
out there so we're gambling by reopening
we understand the challenges of having
an economy and a business and a society
where people have these restrictions but
we need the contact testing we need the
tracing and we need the serologic
testing in order to make decisions about
what to do next a second wave is on the
mind of Prime Minister
justin trudeau to the question that
we're very much focused on is as that
second wave begins or as we start to see
resurgence 'as in a reopened economy how
quickly are we able to contain them and
control them and the ability to do
widespread testing and contact tracing
will be critical we're not anywhere
close to that now since the first case
is emerged just over 1.3 million
Canadians have been tested five percent
of those have been positive and on
average about 28,000 people are being
tested every day some provinces are
further ahead than others Saskatchewan
for example plans to test everyone who
goes back to work outside the home Eric
Sorenson looks at why testing is taking
so long to ramp up are we forging ahead
into a more open economy blindfolded
that's the fear of many health officials
that we will increase kovat exposure
while not testing enough to know if
we're making things worse Quebec is
still averaging close to 600 new cases a
day but not meeting its testing goals of
14,000 daily I'm a big impatient about
it to be tell you the truth
Quebec sim patient and so is Ontario the
two hardest hit provinces is it
frustrating it's frustrating yeah
believe me it's frustrating Doug for
doesn't need persuading on tests
Ontario's goal was to conduct 16,000
every day early this week the province
was averaging less than half that number
we can't just be testing people with
symptoms we have to start going to the
broader public and start testing as many
people as possible
asymptomatic people in fact Ford says a
new plan is coming next week focused on
random testing including people who show
no symptoms in Alberta meantime they're
already testing more aggressively
asymptomatic tests in Brookes and
Calgary where there have been outbreaks
it's a sketch one they have only about
half a dozen cases per day so while the
testing capacity is 1500 daily they're
only doing about 300
seach day as a result Saskatchewan is
offering to test anyone working outside
the home
who wants a test the testing strategy
that's been deployed throughout the
pandemic in Saskatchewan has served us
very well the patchwork of testing
across the country has prompted the
prime minister to offer the Premier's a
national framework we don't want
logistical or financial limitations to
keep anywhere in this country held back
from doing all the testing that is
necessary and not just testing say
experts but contact tracing and
surveillance and only by controlling
another outbreak then the economy opens
successfully and stay open
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto the
Canadian Armed Forces now says 28
soldiers deployed to long-term care
homes have tested positive for kovat 19
there are 12 positive cases among
soldiers in Ontario and 16 in Quebec
nearly 1,700 members of the Armed Forces
are deployed in 25 facilities where
staff have been overwhelmed by the virus
the troops are helping with cleaning
providing food and helping with the
basic needs of residents the federal
government is making more funding
available to indigenous communities an
additional 75 million dollars will help
address the needs of 1 million
indigenous people living in urban
centers and off reserve it will allow
organizations and community groups to
buy meals groceries and laptops for
school children bus protective equipment
and cleaning supplies and provide mental
health services indigenous community
organizations in our cities and off
reserve do crucial work year-round but
these days their services are in high
demand because of the pandemic we need
to make sure they have the resources to
adapt and grow their services so they
can fulfill their important mission the
funding is on top of fifteen million
dollars announced in mid-march for
people who live off reserve they make up
half of Canada's indigenous population
well much hope is resting on the
discovery of a vaccine for ko bid 19
though no vaccine for any coronavirus
which includes strains of the common
cold has ever been created multiple
teams
scientists backed by the biggest
pharmaceutical companies in the world
are now working around the clock and at
least eight potential vaccines have
reached the stage of human clinical
trials but as Jackson prosecco explains
the hard truth is there are no
guarantees in the shuttered US capital
plans for a phased-in reopening make it
clear there's only so much that can
happen until there's a vaccine it is not
an on and off switch we will not be able
to go back to life as we enjoyed it in
February in labs around the world the
race is on to do it faster than it's
ever been done before the vaccine will
come III do think we'll eventually get a
good one whether it's 12 months 18
months 24 months is anyone's guess there
are encouraging signs researchers in
Boston found monkeys infected with kovat
19 developed antibodies prototype
vaccines proved effective too so these
data demonstrate that there is indeed
natural protective immunity to the virus
which is important and underlies the
premise of the vaccine effort a
different study showed promising mice
and guinea pigs and a small human trial
found eight participants produced
antibodies after a single dose what's
the biggest hurdle in getting a vaccine
out there's a market well the hurdle is
demonstration of safety and efficacy and
large-scale clinical trials and then if
then at that point it becomes a bit of a
scale and production problem there are
also voices of caution who warn the
public should brace for the possibility
that a vaccine might never be found it's
gonna be tough to get vaccines that
protect your whole body and protect the
virus from getting in through your
mucous membranes
even with an effective discovery it will
take a Herculean effort to manufacture
and distribute billions of doses needed
to deliver immunity to the world you
don't want to make changes in your own
social distancing with the idea that
there's a vaccine that's around the
corner for now it's a waiting game
perhaps the most difficult waits of our
lives
Jackson Proust go global
News Washington one of the reasons
there's a push to reopen in the u.s. is
because the jobless rate there is higher
than it's ever been more than 2.4
million americans applied for
unemployment benefits last week the
total number is now 38 point six million
all those jobs were lost in just nine
weeks it's nearly ten percent of the
country's population and it's persisting
even though every state now has begun
some level of phased in reopening al
Austin the constant coronavirus news is
the fate of two Canadians being detained
in China Michael Corrigan Michael SPAWAR
were taken into custody shortly after
Canada arrested huawei executive hmong
wong jo at the request of the United
States she's still under house arrest in
Vancouver and the two Michaels are still
in limbo in a Chinese Jail the Prime
Minister was asked about it
today we have seen Chinese officials
linking those two cases from the very
beginning Canada has an independent
judicial system China doesn't work quite
the same way and don't seem to
understand that we do have an
independent judiciary from political
intervention we will continue to follow
and uphold the independence of our
judicial system while we advocate for
the release of the to Michaels who have
been arbitrarily detained by China in
retaliation for a judicial system that
is independent in in the way it
functions our Ottawa bureau chief
Mercedes Stevenson joins me now Mercedes
what did you make of the prime
minister's answer Donna I found it to be
unusually direct I mean for the first
part of the pandemic he didn't even
mention China and publicly criticizing
China is difficult for the government
because they are very much worried about
the well-being of Michael's father and
Michael Kovarik but he came right out
today and said that from the beginning
the Chinese have been linking these two
things that that's not something that
they had done in public the Chinese
government had claimed that spavin
Kovarik were spies Canadian officials
had said that they were being held
arbitrarily everybody knew that this was
linked to Huawei and to the arrests of
mung Wong Jo here in Canada on that
warrant
for the United States but it wasn't
publicly something that politicians were
talking about so I thought that that was
really interesting and it came after the
Ambassador made a very direct link in
our interview on the West block but the
government here while they're being very
direct about what the situation is still
has to be very careful because Michael
Kovarik and Michael SPAWAR
have their lives on the line now I can
tell you the Canada is still actively
negotiating trying to get them out with
international partners but there has
been no consular access to those two men
since January when we asked the Chinese
ambassador about that this is what he
had to say and the father to Canadian
citizens we are making sure that they
receive you know all those treatment you
know you know in accordance with law so
that's why you're even this outbreak we
have provided better for them Donna
there has not been so much as a phone
call or video call for Canada to be able
to check on the well-being the
ambassador they're saying that their
diet has improved which leaves one to
wonder what they were eating in the
first place so Canadian officials are
concerned about their well-being and
there's yet another step to come in this
drama on Wednesday the Supreme Court of
British Columbia will release one of
their decisions on the Huawei
extradition case but that won't be where
the story ends there is still more
before the courts and the possibility
that moong Wong Joe could appeal
whatever the court decides Donna
all right Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa
thanks community services and facilities
under threat coming up what could vanish
because of the virus plus the sight to
behold from Nepal's capital
restrictions are beginning to ease
across the country but many of the
recreational facilities we've grown
accustomed to remain closed and some may
stay that way
municipalities across the country are
suffering financially and have lost
billions as Abigail Beeman reports pools
arenas and city manage gold courses
could be the long-term victims planned
upgrades and a new fire truck on hold in
this Ontario town to make up for a
köppen 19 shortfall where a municipality
we can't run a deficit so we have to
ensure that we have a balanced budget
the small municipality of 17,000 expects
to lose hundreds of thousands of dollars
this summer in facility rentals alone
and they've already seen property tax
non payments double while bigger cities
like Halifax are at the point of
considering cutting essential services
what's in the draft cuts right now is a
five million dollar up to bond to fire a
five million dollar cut to police and
that's just simply not sustainable the
Federation of Canadian Municipalities
says in total cities need between ten
and fifteen billion dollars this year to
get out of the Cova 19 hole they're
calling on the federal government to
help it is dire and this is a crises a
big chunk of the lost revenue transit
I'm down five hundred bus drivers right
now because demand is lower and I don't
have a way to hire them back when we
turn the economy back on and we need
more buses and more space on transit
Edmonton has already cut 4200 jobs with
rec centers and libraries shut down Bret
the point now where the next round of
cuts we would have to make would be
either to infrastructure and the jobs
associated with them or or to essential
services I think what worries us is
everything rolls downhill back and can't
build these business owners no municipal
cuts mean more than just a loss in city
services we are a center of the
community where we're just as a big
support and in funding as well as
what we receive make people go into the
pool that stop by and they don't do that
anymore and we're no longer the draw for
the downtown core the federal government
says they're aware of the challenges
facing municipalities and they're ready
to help but there have been no specific
promises in response to that request for
up to 15 billion dollars
Abigail Beeman at Global News Ottawa a
deadly cyclone slammed Southeast Asia
ahead why some refused to flee their
homes
you are watching global national the
most powerful storm to hit eastern India
and Bangladesh in over a decade has left
a wide swath of destruction many coastal
areas are flooded millions of people are
without power
cyclone am Pam came ashore yesterday
pounding the region with heavy rain
strong winds and a five-meter storm
surge more than 80 people have died many
were electrocuted or killed by falling
trees authorities in both countries
urged more than 3 million people to move
to emergency shelters before it hit
police say some were unwilling to go out
of fear of contracting kovat 19 for the
first time in decades people in Nepal
can see the world's tallest mountain
from a distance the snow-capped peak of
Mount Everest is now visible from
Kathmandu Valley 200 kilometers away
it's usually hidden by haze and air
pollution
Nepal's Kovach 19 lockdown has cut down
emissions and that has cleared the air
sudden outbreak next how the novel
coronavirus spread through one Alberta
community
[Music]
the most deadly outbreaks of kovat 19 in
Canada have been in long-term care homes
but there's a cautionary tale in Alberta
about how the virus can spread through a
community Brooks in southern Alberta has
one of the worst outbreaks in the
country it's a small city about two
hours southeast of Calgary in mid-march
Brooks had no cases at all by mid April
the virus suddenly seemed to be
everywhere heather Eurex West looks at
why it spread so quickly for weeks
miriam Funes husband had been taking
special precautions at work each day at
the jbs meatpacking plant he wore a mask
and a face shield and was careful to
remove his clothes and decontaminate
before coming home each night still in
early April he became sick he filled the
body pains sore throat and fever
cheering at night and then after three
days I got my son from still both tested
positive for kovat 19 at the height of
the outbreak here Brooks had more than a
thousand cases of copán 19 for a
community of less than 15,000 people
that meant that virtually everyone knew
somebody that was sick it was after the
easter long weekend we started to see
some cases and and the numbers started
to go up Brooks recorded its first three
cases on April 14th by the nineteenth
three had become more than 100 and the
numbers kept climbing by the end of the
month nearly 1,000 people were infected
we were having an increase of hundred or
more per day and we were also looking at
High River and what having a high river
two hours west of Brooks the community
of High River Alberta had been
experiencing a similar outbreak the two
communities have a lot in common both
are incredibly diverse with large
numbers of residents traveling to work
at a nearby meatpacking plant each day
throughout the outbreak the jbs plant
outside Brooks never shut down but it
did cut the second shift and provided
protective gear for workers on the floor
but this employee says on a noisy shop
floor the extra gear often got in the
way of required tasks and so she says
safety protocols weren't always followed
so you need to take off your face shield
and sometimes you need to
to be thanked Oh whew yeah so be good
did that happen off yeah mm-hmm yeah
honestly yeah
the company says all employees received
safety training and that supervisors
were on the floor to enforce the new
rules but health officials say the
outbreak and Brooks didn't come from the
jbs facility alone it's not just linked
to the large meat plant in Brooks it
really truly was a community outbreak
and we had multitude of outbreaks and in
multiple locations there's a lot of
Filipino people who got sick from areum
funa it was a terrifying time her
community was under siege carpooling to
work in multiple generations and
families living in one home in the
situation that much more challenging the
steps that would be taken by everyone in
the coming days would make or break a
possible disaster
Heather Eric's West Global News Brooks
Alberta tomorrow Heather we'll look at
how Brooks Alberta managed to swiftly
curb the outbreak there and that is
global national for this Thursday I'm
Donna Friesen we thought it was time to
resume a new normal here at global
national so York Canada is back this is
the British Columbia Institute of
Technology marine campus on the
waterfront in North Vancouver it's where
students trained to work in the maritime
industry we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to viewers at global
national comm thanks for watching take
care of yourselves
bye bye
[Music]